hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the 2018 European team Cup
it's a game between Polish number one
Grandmaster rather slow voice check and
magnus carlsen
who's playing board one for his valor
wrong a chess club from Oslo and now
it's very interesting I don't know if
you remember when we were covering tiles
climbing to the chest Olympus and his
preparations for his big match against
Mikhail Botvinnik it was very odd that
tal for his preparation decided to play
an open tournament in Riga I usually you
know the practice was if you're about to
challenge the World Chess Champion you
know you should go to your training camp
and there you know just prepare up until
the match starts you know don't show
anything you've prepared and don't play
any games and that was very very odd
that tall decided to do that which our
other challengers before him did not but
now we have Fabiano caruana before the
World Chess Championship match is
playing the Olympia and here cousin is
playing the European team Cup so the
times have definitely changed and now I
wanted to show you something these are
their these are the standings of their
previous encounters so as you can see a
regarding classical games Magnus cross
and beat tirado Slovakia Czech four to
one with zero draws so very interesting
and ok including rapid exhibition games
he beat him
5 to 1 so they played one rapid a slash
exhibition game so very interesting all
of the games they played were decisive
and it seems that now a Voyager has a
chance with the white pieces the perhaps
you know lower cousins lead and also we
have a nice photo challenge it's also a
joke
here is the playing hall of the 2018
European team Cup so try to locate both
Coulson and voyeur sure in this photo
there we have it I best of luck to
everyone and we also have some nice
footage by Nikki Riga so I hope you
enjoyed this as well before we check out
the game so let's check it out here we
have
a nice close-up photo shoot so let's
let's just check it out for the moment
is this is raw footage so you know the
best kind of footage
and David Carson is not at the board so
that the board okay Carson comes back at
the board and also here we have a nice a
nice forceful cross and you know
considering what to do
just in order to get you in the mood for
this game and also to see how the world
champion is enjoying his time before the
World Chess Championship match so there
we have it and now let's check out this
game boy - Shaq has the white pieces and
he opens with d4 Knight to f6 by cross
and c4 g6 sorry about that so the Kings
Indian defense is on the board and now
Knight to f3 Bishop to g7 and the g3
mostly nowadays everyone plays g3
against the Kings Indian defense I will
have castles Bishop to g2 and c6 now and
okay
Knight to c3 we have d5 expanding the
pawn all the way to the center C
captures C captures and now Knight to e5
a very nice move as centralizing this
Knight this point has already been
pushed to d5 so there's no way to kick
it away from there and moving this night
and trying to kick it away with f6 with
worse in your position and you would
waste too much time so an excellent move
and here black can definitely develop
this bishop we a bishop to f5 many games
were played this way but here costs and
decides the fianchetto the light square
bishop as well as the dark square bishop
we have castles Bishop to b7 and now
Bishop to f4 now Carlsen can develop the
knight to c6 we have looked the c1
developing the rook and placing it on
the only open file on the board rook the
c8 Carson does the same and now Queen to
d2 a very nice move that connects rooks
develops the Queen and also creates this
battery that perhaps Bishop to h6 will
be an idea in the future we have e6 by
Carlsen and the now comes rope the c2
this rook to c2 already on move 13 we
have a position that was never before
seen on the board vojta Shakir is
preparing to double up rooks on the C
file and now Carlson has to decide what
to do here first he trades off a pair of
Knights nightcap rosani 5 and now Bishop
captures on e5 capturing what the pawn
isn't all that impressive view your
darks
Bishop simply becomes a pawn and there's
really not nothing to gain from this
pawn being on e5 after Knight to g4
black is already threatening to
recapture it and there's really no good
way to prevent this
so after Knight captures on e5 Bishop
captures on e5 and now comes Knights the
e8 we have Bishop captures and g17
captures on g7 and not rook F the c1
nice to d6 by Carlsen here
capturing with the king that seems to be
the way to go as if you capture with the
night the night has better squares from
EA to enter the game for example Knight
d6 to c4 or efore and from g7 it
wouldn't be all that great rook F 2 c1
avoid a shark finally doubles rooks on
the C file and now Knight to d6 calls
and brings the knight into the game
b3 taking away the c-4 square from the
night and now comes Queen to f6
pressuring the d4 pawn and since all
avoid the tricks pieces are pretty much
ideally placed now he simply plays a III
and forces the pawn in the center and
also now all of his bones around dark
dark squares he has a light square
bishop so always well for white here
bunch of 286 now Costas Bishop wasn't
doing all that much here so now he moves
it to a much better diagonal we have a
four and grabbing more space on the
Queen side and also perhaps taking away
the b5 square from the night Queen to e7
now cousin wants to exchange all of the
rooks along the C file and then bring
his Queen into the game also via the C
file night to 8 to avoid a shock offers
the trader rooks and cross and accepts
rogue captures rook captures and wrote
the c8 costs almost the trade off other
Perl groups as well rook captures on c8
and now Bishop captures on c8 it seems
like an odd decision to capture with the
bishop since the bishop is already a
placed on a such a nice diagonal so
perhaps Knight captures on c8 would have
been better but it seems not because now
Voyager could bring this knight back
into the game with tempo for example
night here attacks the bishop on e6 and
after Bishop here now comes Queen to c3
controlling the C file also Knight to c6
would be
so after something like queen bee seven
nights the d3 now and now the night has
a lot of a lot of other useful squares
here perhaps the black would have to
week in this position would have six so
Carson's idea definitely is the way to
go but characters on c8 and now a5
Voyager wants to create weaknesses on
the Queen side Queen to c7 a capture Sun
b6 Queen capture some b6 and now Queen
two before offering a queen trade bunch
of to a6 Carson doesn't mind he simply
improves the position of his bishop and
now Queen captures on b6 a capture Sun
b6 and now comes Knight to c3 so pretty
much in a dead equal position the
material on the board completely even
both players with a light square bishop
only if you well if you really study it
it seems that way - Shakir has all of
his pawns on dark squares and he has a
light square bishop and Carson has all
of his pawns on light squares and also
has a light square bishop so it seems
cross and has a bad [ __ ] whereas Voytik
has a good bishop but the position is
not static all of the pawns can still be
moved so this isn't such a huge of an
advantage and there are still Knights on
the board so Bishop to d3 by Carlsen we
have Bishop to f1 offering a trade of
bishops and for now cost and the clients
that attacks the b3 pawn and now before
we have 93 for offering a trade of
knights now and now nice to be 500 shark
is the one who decides to not the trade
nights seems like could be a dangerous
idea as the be for pawn is now unguarded
and also it's on a dark square so
perhaps Carlsen could maneuver his
knight in such a way to perhaps be able
to capture it but there's a really no
good way to do it 92 it's simply too far
away from the pawn Knight here is
impossible as the knight is covering
this square so it seems there's no way
to take advantage of this rush up to D 1
by Carlsen we have Bishop to d3 and now
again declining the trade nice to d2 and
Knight back to c3 attacking Carlsen
special Bishop to b3 and King to g2 now
Bishop to c4 and now Bishop to see to
avoid a shock declines the trade but
even if you trade wish ups here but cap
site captures and there's still nothing
to do here by either player so after
Bishop c4 Bishop c2 was played I would
have a bishop to f1 check King to g1 and
mushroom back to c4 King G - and now
Carlsen doesn't repeat Bishop to f1
Check Writer g5 is played I will have g4
by voice - record Bishop to f1 check
King g3 and now Knight to the c4 we have
h4 h 6 by Carlson captures captures and
Bishop to a for now Knights the b2
attacking the bishop bishop back to c2
and now comes King to f6 cross and
brings his king into the game f4 I would
have Bishop to d3 and now Bishop to b3 a
bishop to c4 we have brush up the c2
Bishop to d3 Bishop to b3 Bishop to c4
and Bishop to see to hear the players
agree to a draw as there really is
nothing more to do here you can simply a
trade of a pair of pawns but after that
there's really nothing to do material
and the board is completely equal and
the position is completely equal so
after Bishop to see - a draw was agreed
upon and cousin Steele still keeps his
number one spot in the world chess
rating list but if he if he perhaps
loses his today's game if he will be
playing his at the today's game then
Fabiano Caruana will be the new number
one rated player in the world so it's
really really an ordered decision that
you would decide to do this perhaps he
really doesn't care about rating but he
himself said in an interview not so long
ago that it would he really wouldn't
like it if Caruana became the new number
one rated player in the world or or
mommy dr of during the Olympiad as he's
been number one rated player even before
he became world champion so it he really
wouldn't enjoy it so it seems a very odd
that he would play this European team
team Cup before facing Caruana in the
World Chess Championship final in the
world championship match so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
what do you think is it what's the
correct approach or playing the
tournament before facing the
champion or you know it depends from
whose perspective you're considering is
it good for Caruana to play a tournament
before facing Carlsen and is it good for
cause and to be playing a tournament
before facing Caruana so there you have
it I do hope you enjoy that I would like
to thank Michael Yaffe no Michael
McMahon damnit forest America Garretson
and Travis James for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I'll see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content I'm definitely going to publish
game 14 of the officials basketball
championship match and as usual thanks
to Nikki Riga for all the nice photos
and videos feel free to follow Nikki the
links to all of her social media pages
will be in the description below thank
you all and I will see you soon